One day I was walking to school
when a man tried to force me into a car
where another man was waiting.
I kicked and screamed.
People on the streets rushed to help me.
And they eventually let me go.
My family and I left Iraq the next day.
A local militia had threatened
the associated press
where my dad was a reporter.
The militia was upset with
recent coverage of its activities
and ended up murdering his colleague
and lodging a bullet
in the head of his three-year-old son.
After a shock of what
happened to me wore off,
my parents joked that
kidnappers changed their minds
after being exposed to what
I was like as a teenager.
This is the kind of humor
that Iraqis are known for,
the darker, the better.
And it's one reason that Ahmed Albasheer,
the country's most
influential media figure
has managed to capture
the hearts of Iraqis.
Half of Iraq's total population
regularly tunes into his show.
Albasheer was born and
raised in Ramadi, Iraq,
which experienced the
worst of the Iraq war.
He lost several family members,
including his brother and father.
In 2005, he was kidnapped
and tortured by a Shia militia.
16 years later,
Albasheer has built a
remarkably successful show
by criticizing the Iraqi
government and its corruption.
I spoke to Albasheer at
the Oslo Freedom Forum,
a conference that gathers
media figures, activists,
and dissidents to talk
about government oppression
and human rights violations
all over the world.
Albasheer and I talked
about the situation in Iraq
and the Iraqi elections.
They say before Saddam,
we have one Saddam.
Now we have a thousand Saddam.
Every corner in Iraq,
there is a small dictator
and whoever says anything about him,
he would be killed publicly.
I wanted to joke about
escaping my kidnappers,
but I thought it might be inappropriate
since he couldn't escape his.
You think that was funny?
I think that's funny.
I think it's hilarious.